all right problem 79
what is the domain of the function shown
on the graph below and that sounds like
a fancy word but a function is just a
rule it's just a rule that maps from one
set of numbers to another and the set of
numbers that it maps from is the domain
and the set of numbers that it maps to
is the range
so if we were to
so
if this is a set of numbers a domain
this is a set of numbers of the range
the function tells us how do we get from
this number someplace in the domain to
that number
someplace in the range right
so in general the domain is all the
numbers for which this mapping or this
function is defined
so in this example oh boy no there's not
enough space let me copy and paste it at
the bottom of this thing now i have
enough space
okay so let's see so the domain is where
is this function domain defined so let's
see if we so this function is defined
for
x is equal to and in general when you
plot it on the x y axis the domain is
all of the x values that you're defined
over and the range is all the y values
so the function is a mapping from x
to y
so let's see where it's defined when x
is equal to 4 it tells us we're mapping
from
x is equal to four to y is equal to
negative one so it's defined for x is
equal to four
for x is equal to five
for x is equal to two
right x equal to two and it's defined
for x is equal to one so it's defined
for all of those numbers that's the
domain this function is not defined we
don't know what happens when x is equal
to -2 it's not defined it tells us no it
doesn't tell us what y equals here so
this is the only these are the only
numbers for which this function is
defined it tells us that 4 maps to
negative one
four maps to negative one that five maps
to negative two
that two maps to minus five
and that one maps to minus four
that's all it tells us and these this is
actually the range
that's the range and that's the domain
that's the domain
so let's see four five two one
four five two one right this is the this
is the domain that's that's the set of
all numbers for which the function is
defined
this minus one two five and four
this is the range right here right here
choice b is the range
all right
i think we're on the last problem
this is going to be a lot of cutting and
pasting i don't know if it's going to
fit
just shrink it
okay they said which of the following is
not a function that's fascinating
okay
copied it
and now i have pasted it and it did all
barely fit
on this page
so which is not a function and remember
what i said in the beginning i don't
have space below here let's think about
what a function is and then we can look
at the graph and becomes so a function
is a mapping from one set to another
from set a to set b
where a is the domain and b is the range
and this is the important thing to
realize about a function so this is set
a
and if this is set b
that for any value in set a it only maps
to one value in set b
you cannot have this you can't have one
value in set a going to this value and
going to another value
so let's see which of these so this is
that would not make it a function
you can't have one if we say x is the
domain if this is the set of all values
that we can put into x and this is all
the set of values go into y or that can
be y
then one value of x can't produce two
values of y
right you can have it the other way
around you can have two different values
of x producing the same value of y
and we'll think about what that is so
let's see that's completely valid like
you could have two numbers when x is
equal to 2 and x is equal to 7 you can
still have y equaling the same thing but
you can't have
x equal say this is x is equal to 5. you
can't x equals a 5 could be y is equal
to 7 or x is equal to 5 could be y is
equal to 8. we don't know that so let's
see let's think about how we can
visually think about this
so here
for every value and for every value of x
we only have one definition for y right
and people often call that the vertical
line test at no point on this graph can
i draw a vertical line and it intersects
it twice if you intersected if a
vertical line intersected twice that
means for a given value of x this
function defines two different y's not
going to happen now this function does
this function does for what any given y
have two different x's right
for like that point and that point
but that's okay that's completely fine
so for example when x is equal to minus
one and a half and x is equal to three
they point to the same number
so in that example that's like you know
x is equal to minus one and a half and x
is equal to three they both point to the
same number
that's completely okay as long as one of
these don't point to two separate
numbers
so that magenta is what that first graph
is doing
same thing here we have you know
for any given y we can have two x's
pointing to it
but for the vertical line and this is
fine that's completely fine for a
function now when we talk about function
inverses that well i don't get too
complicated that's completely fine but
if we do the vertical line test at no
point can we draw a vertical line
and get for any given x two separate y's
same thing for here actually here we
have a complete one to one mapping for
any given x there's one y
and i think here it should be clear that
if i were to draw a vertical line
let's say right there
i have for one x let's say for x is
equal to two there's what two actually
let's do it more interesting for x is
equal to one
for x is equal to one it has two
definitions well it's even better for x
is equal to zero y could be minus two
or plus two
so that's the case that we said for an x
is equal to zero
it's pointing to plus two
and it's pointing to minus two it's
pointing to two different values
which you cannot have in a function for
a function for any given x you can only
define one y value
so this one is this relation is not a
function d
next question
think this is the last
it's a page on its own
oh that was the last question was that
did i skip a problem see that was 80.
i did 79 up that's it we're all done all
right see you soon